kelly ripa and mark consuelos's youngest
kiddo
is all grown up and off to prom
you two are closer to an empty nest this
close
we are truly this close we are down to
one we are down to one
the proud parents shared these snaps of
their son joaquin
on tuesday check him out with his date
heading off to the big dance
kelly captioned her post quote prom
night 2021
joaquin and melissa while mark echoed
that
writing quote it's prom night the 50
year old tv personality also shared some
behind the scenes moments from her son's
prom
night like this pic of mark helping
their son straighten his tie
joaquin throwing on his jacket then mark
coming in with the assist again to
adjust his collar
kelly also shared this family pic before
posting
these snaps of joaquin and his date in
march joaquin announced that he'll be
attending the university of michigan in
the fall
go blue and we'll be joining the
wrestling team
at the time the 18 year old shared this
post on instagram
writing quote super excited to step into
this next chapter with university of
michigan wrestling
honored to be part of this great program
and
after joaquin shared the news kelly
proudly posted
this pic of her son with his dad posing
it up in university of michigan hoodies
writing quote sunday vibes mark
very emotional and very choked up
because he said you know
i never thought he would be able to go
to college because he was
profoundly dyslexic and dysgraphic back
in february
kelly opened up on live with kelly and
ryan about how proud she was of joaquin
and said that with hard work and
determination he was able to overcome
his challenges
i always say that dyslexia for our
family
at least and if you read about it it can
be
quite a blessing kids with dyslexia
learn how to
read the room they pick up on social
cues as for the couple's other kiddos 23
year old michael and
19 year old lola both stayed closer to
home for college
choosing nyu and in 2019
kelly joked to e.t about counting down
the days until her kids moved out of the
family home
i'm truly going to be running through
the house naked i just want everybody to
know that
i'm gonna be sitting on every piece of
furniture naked be warned before you
come over
that's what i'll be doing in my spare
time and you're welcome america
you